so going from having a boss to being
your own boss how do you keep yourself
on track because i would imagine it's so
easy to get sidetracked
from
you're used to punching in or being at a
job and then you're your own boss and
this is ultimately up to you how do you
be your own task master so to speak like
keep yourself on track and not yeah you
know check facebook every 10 minutes or
yeah keeping myself on track is
definitely one of the challenges when i
work for myself you know
partly because when you're working on a
variety of films you have films that are
in release so you're trying to promote
those then you want to develop new ideas
and then you also sometimes need to edit
a film you've got all these different
things going on in any given moment
because you you know you've got multiple
titles and you're like
sometimes it's easy to shut down or get
overwhelmed so
i just have one of those minds that puts
pressure on myself and those around me
like you know sometimes i i worry about
my wife who i work with on films now
because i'm constantly basically getting
up in the mornings and just
a lot of times they're mental but i'm
putting together these lists of trying
to make sure each day i'm you know
checking things off those lists
sometimes they're you know in
spreadsheets and a little bit more like
planned out
um but it's it's very important for me
to make sure that like every day i've
got i'm making some kind of progress you
know when i get a chance to travel and
i'm in a place
like la or new york i'm trying to set up
as many meetings as i can
because you never know when a meeting
might lead to an opportunity or
might might you know might give you some
new ideas or give you some opportunities
so
i definitely have to put a lot of
pressure though on myself because it's
it's it's difficult you know it's not
like having a job where you you know you
walk in and you've got your day-to-day
tasks and then you can kind of leave and
and go home so at the same time i'm also
trying to figure out how to make sure
i'm not over
you know overdoing things or wasting a
lot of time on stuff that's not going to
really pan out so i'm trying to i'm
trying to look at what i'm doing and
constantly reevaluating and thinking
about past projects and going well did
that did that really work
i found that
if i set up bigger sort of periods of
time that are dedicated to one type of
thing that i'm more more effective
so for example
walter was essentially done and edit
ready for release and we were trying to
figure out exactly how we're going to
roll out walter
and
i was sitting around feeling like i was
not being very efficient because it was
over the summer i wasn't sure you know
when exactly we're going to release and
so
we sat down with our team and said okay
let's make a plan on when we're
releasing but let's also design a
kickstarter campaign crowdfunding
campaign that'll help make that release
happen and really put our energy into
that that crowdfunding campaign and so i
remember that period of time where i
felt
inefficient i felt like i really wasn't
progressing and once we sort of had a
really good solid plan that would take
over the next few months of our
life and time then
it's like the ball started rolling other
meetings started coming new you know new
projects
came in there there was like a certain
sort of energy that was um that came
about and of course it helped that our
kickstarter campaign was successful
takes a lot of work but that was
ultimately you know a good example of
how
productivity was back in place and you
know after this phase we've got another
month or so of this phase we'll get into
sort of a hot you know holiday time
it'll slow down a little bit and so
we'll see you know we'll see sort of
what the next plan maybe that'll be more
of a development time where we write
write out some ideas and really focus on
on some things like that but i like to
kind of section off these little periods
of
of the year or or whatever to really
focus on
one aspect of a project